[Music]
all right so welcome to session number
28 of the world two speculative fiction
series in which we attack the world
building and Agri fees and philosophical
themes different speculative fiction
authors today we have somebody who was
like the hands-down winner when I pulled
people about who we should do next on
the Internet
not so much for the face-to-face
discussions but somehow Robert Howard
was immensely popular he beat up every
other candidate hands down several times
over and I've been a big fan of Howard
when I was a kid so I thought it would
be good to return to the Conan stories
and take a look at those so you know
let's let's let's get started I'll just
mention a little bit about my own
interest in Kony on you know growing up
as a kid in the 70s in the 80s of course
there's on Conan the Barbarian and the
movie you know a formative age and I
think for a lot of young guys many of us
you know wanted to be Conan and of
course couldn't he's sort of meaningful
way because he was gigantic and all that
but I didn't realize you know until I
started reading the books which I also
started reading in my my let's call the
formative years how much of a divergence
the movie was from the character in the
books who's a lot smarter a lot more
articulate than Schwarzenegger was able
to convey or I think was allowed to the
script in the other direction so Howard
I was you know I'd only really read the
Conan's stuff I think I read a few of
the Solomon Kane and call stories
because people had recommended them I
had no idea just how vast is his output
was until I started looking at
biographies of him earlier this year I
had no idea how short his career was for
somebody who ended up becoming so
influential it's unfortunate he died a
very young man you know comparatively
speaking right maybe not for four
some people they might think of a young
man is 18 or 20 or something like that
he was you know just 30 when he died I
think but he had a very pretentious
output for for that time period and he
never published a book in his lifetime
everything was just through the pulp so
though the books that we see on the
shelves now whether they're his original
stories or the stories as edited by
people like L Sprague de Kamp or Lin
Carter or some of the later we had it's
or the other conan stories by other
people those would be kind of foreign to
him it'd be interesting if we had him
here right now we could show him his own
books what he might make of that so
let's let's talk about his his biography
first because in a way the
world-building stuff I think is going to
come in naturally out of the discussion
of philosophical themes he is a Texan
and in a way an archetypal Texan of that
time he lives in an oil boom area
he doesn't venture much out of the state
but that gives him quite a wide range he
would talk about taking these automobile
trips where they would drive to another
County and you know for us Midwesterners
you know here like in Waukesha County
Milwaukee County is just down the road
and what's the though to the west of us
is it died and it's not Dodge that's a
couple more down yeah but but you know
Texas counties are almost like the size
of small states
so he really ranged quite a ways and
it's interesting so he's born to this
guy Isaac who's a doctor and Hester
Howard in peace tur Texas which is not
their hometown they just happened to be
there for the birth and within you know
a period of nine years the family
relocates from one town to the next to
the next
the next and there were there were some
tensions as sounds like there's a
soundtrack from a movie behind us some
film thing so so he's you know there's
not a lot of stability there and
apparently his father was kind of
pursuing this oil boom thing trying to
get rich in one way or another moving
from from place to place and each of
these is just a small town that doesn't
you know have any great meaning or
anything by itself and then finally they
move to cross plains in 1919 and that's
where they'll establish a household so
he's already you know 13 by that time
and then he sees it so imagine he's just
you know going into like you know high
school he sees crossplane
not just double but go six times its
population because it becomes an oil
boomtown and he sees all these these
people coming through Howard actually
there's a great thing that he wrote
about in oil boom he says I'll say one
thing about an oil boom it'll teach a
kid that life's a pretty rotten thing
about it quick about as quick as
anything I can think of and so he saw
all these people coming in trying to
make money and then all the other people
who kind of feed on them and service
them people selling them you know hot
dogs and hamburgers all the way from
that sort of stuff and clothes selling
to prostitutes to people catering all
sorts of tastes people were getting in
fights all the time some people would
actually drive from other Taos and just
sit there and watch to see fights break
out and then you had all the other
people who came in to to take advantage
of that speculators you know people
selling all sorts of other other things
to them and and then he kind of took
that to heart I think I think it's
reflected in his views on civilization
you know both that it's a thin veneer
over a rock rather seedy underside which
i think is pretty true
yeah and that things can change so
quickly too I mean imagine the
difference between like that and his
friend and correspondent HP Lovecraft
you know living in Providence this this
town where you know things are happening
very slowly
Lovecraft goes to New York and doesn't
like it in part because you know there's
there's too much turnover of people's
and property so he starts reading pulp
magazines and then he just decides he
wants to start writing and he starts to
accumulate rejection slips hey come on
in
good to see you so then he and his
mother eventually moved to this town
Brownwood because he couldn't finish
high school in the town that he was
living in and they had a high school
there and he starts to get published in
the school paper the Tabler and win some
prizes there's some early essays by him
and there and some stories and he starts
to publish in other places as well he
graduates from high school and then he
starts actually selling stories he sells
this spear and fame to Weird Tales and
that's really important because weird
tales will become one of the main
outlets for for howard's writing and
weird tales would actually pay you know
decent money for these stories so the
other thing you notice sometimes it's
called a bookkeeping course and
sometimes it's called the stenography
course but there is a a business college
Howard Payne College there in town and
his dad wanted him his dad was a doctor
that wanted him to have a practical
career so he didn't want him doing all
this writing stuff hey come on in and
his he made a deal with his dad he would
he would try his hand at writing and if
that didn't work out then he would
definitely become a bookkeeper
stenographer you know do something
business oriented something practical
and around that time he also starts this
program of weightlifting and boxing and
he becomes a real
tough guy he gets huge he choosing her
Schwarzenegger his Conan is kind of kind
of fitting right because because that
was his total digression but that was
his breakout role until then he was just
this Austrian bodybuilder that everyone
thought was kind of dumb Howard was was
thought of as being kind of a nerd or a
[ __ ] and he'd get picked on it's almost
like that you remember those Charles
Atlas commercials yeah the guy gets like
sand kicked in his face by the big tough
guy so he starts you know lifting
weights so that was Robert Howard you
know and then he started you know
settling scores he got into boxing too
and anyway he's working a bunch of
different jobs at the time trying to
make money and and he quits this soda
jerk job because that that's sort of the
last straw for him he's working like 12
hours a day and a soda fountain you know
one of those paper hits pouring sodas
for people and he's like this I've had I
can't get any writing done so he starts
the bookkeeping course again and he does
finish the course and he attempts to
become a professional writer and it
takes him a while but he finally starts
publishing you know more and more things
hey I don't have in the book not the
books with the stories I only have some
of the stories in there his output was a
lot larger than that and as a matter of
fact I went through and I am belated the
different genres that he wrote in so he
wrote fantasy and all the all the
stories that are in this time like these
are all fantasy stories strict fantasy
he also wrote historical stories with
different characters and those are kind
of like fantasy stories but they're more
of what we would call historical fiction
at this time then he also had western
stories you know well familiar to us as
a genre but he also had things that are
called weird westerns where it became a
blend of a Western and then some horror
or or something else in there he wrote
some comedy stories in the 20s early on
and he also wrote some horror stories
including some Tula mythos stories a lot
of people were trying her hand at that
but the most interesting thing that I
had no idea about til I started looking
into this a lot of his output was where
I called boxing stories and these were
actually like stories about people in
the ring boxing with other guys you
might say well who the hell would want
to read that there was a huge readership
for this sort of thing I suppose in part
because you know there wasn't any
television it was a big sport in America
at the time and people were attracted to
it so he was you know writing that sort
of stuff and he actually started making
some decent money so in 1926 he made I
they have a listing here of what he made
so he made $50 writing stories which at
that time was the equivalent of about
maybe 700 bucks now so not too bad and
then by 1929 he was making over 10 times
that he made seven hundred and seventy
two dollars that's around the time that
he's publishing his first call story one
of the first boxing stories that Steve
Costigan and then it goes up from there
so until except for 1933 he didn't have
a year under a thousand bucks after that
which and a thousand bucks at that time
was a lot of money and this is during
the Depression at one point in time he
was the person in his town who was
making the most money and he was a
20-something year old kid doing this in
Texas so you can imagine that it could
have you know gone to his head perhaps a
little bit so if we follow his timeline
but he he starts selling stories to
other magazines and the first conan
stuff starts coming up around the turn
of the decade one of the things he does
is takes a call he'd already done well
with these call stories and he he got
one rejected so he's like well I'm gonna
try to do something different with us so
he takes a story
and he rewrites it but now it's not call
it's Conan if they turns that into the
Phoenix on the sword which which will
get published in 1932 and that's one of
his first Conan stories he starts to
submit stories to this oriental stories
which is kind of spinoff of Weird Tales
starts a correspondence with with HP
Lovecraft loses everything in the
depression because you know like most
banks his collapsed I imagine it was
probably worse in Texas you know than
many other places and then he starts by
1932 he's starting to do World War II if
you think about it the Conan stories are
you know he died young so we don't know
what he would have done say if he'd
lived in news 40s or 50s but the Quarian
stories are the last big attempt for him
to write fantasy stuff as a matter of
fact the year he dies 30 36 he's not
writing much fantasy stuff he's instead
concentrating on westerns which he was
you know pretty interested in writing
about and plenty of material to to work
from but why are the Conan stories
particularly good well he's gone already
through a cycle of writing about call
Solomon Kane these Celtic Heroes Barak
mock morn and turtle all doob that I
don't think anybody reads that that's
stuff anymore
and then this Texan james Allison who he
wrote a lot of stories about this Texan
who has like these
what would know I think it's called past
life experiences and sort of flashbacks
and then you write a story about that so
he had he'd already done the work
shopping in effect now not work shopping
in the sense of like going to a Writers
Workshop he's he's essentially
self-taught as a writer and he's looking
at what will actually make it into the
magazines is his criterion for what
works I guess would be what does the
public actually respond to what are the
editors say this is good
what you know what makes them a decent
amount of money a very pragmatic way of
doing it but so you notice that in in
from like 1933 to 1935 that's the the
main output of his Conan stories and
almost all of the fantasy stories he's
writing at that time our Conan stories
he's writing other stuff too but that's
that's where this is happening and he
also does get a girlfriend in 1934 and
she's got kind of an interesting story
herself she she'd been the girlfriend of
one of his friends before that and she
arrives in Cross Plains her name is
novalee in price and she made some
attempts to call Howard only to be told
by his mother we can talk a little bit
about his mother in a bit I think we
probably should that he couldn't come to
the phone you know she's like trying to
brush him off can brush her off I guess
his mother thought she wasn't good for
him or something like that
so she actually rides out to his house
and tries to meet him his dad is not
happy about that but but Howard you know
comes out and they meet and they talk
and it turns out they have a lot of
things in common
she's interest she's teaching and she's
interested in English history and public
speaking so this is right up his alley
and they they start this this romance
which is kind of a you know it never
really goes anywhere and that's a matter
of fact given the opportunity eventually
to break it off and get out of town in
1936
novalee does that she goes off to
graduate school but but in the meantime
you know like they'd start talking about
marriage and things like that when one
of them would start talking about the
other one to get kind of cool you know
she'd start talking about it Howard and
start talking about how
his independence and things like that
and then when when he would talk about
it she would talk about their
differences so things somehow never
never really worked up and that was a
great love of his life yeah so and you
know he was fairly young at the time and
then so she leaves for Louisiana State
and that's that's that meanwhile he's
writing and things are starting to get
kind of tough in the household
his mother is sick she'd been sick for
quite a while she had tuberculosis and
she'd contracted it actually taking care
of other relatives who had tuberculosis
so and she's in a doctor's household too
so her her medical bills start to pile
up because she has to go to sanatoriums
and hospitals and eventually Isaac he
moves his medical practice out of the
office that he'd been renting into the
house and meanwhile Robert is you know
frantically trying to sell stuff one of
the the big issues with selling things
to the pulps is they would pay you on
publication rather than paying you
upfront they'd only pay you when the
issue came up so if they delayed your
story you might not get paid for a while
when he died Weird Tales owed him
something like a thousand bucks which I
think got page was his father or
something like that and the tragic story
that that ends it all is his his mother
eventually you know succumbs to the
disease ends up in a coma he goes to his
dad asks his dad if somebody was shot in
the head you know would that in effect
like kill them permanently or is there
any chance that like they might might
survive it and his dad you know not
thinking when it says no I mean that'll
kill you and so while his mother is you
know dying in this coma he goes out in
his car and shoots himself at his head
and doesn't die right away so his dad
wasn't completely right but he does die
I think if I remember right about six
hours later
so think about what it must have been
like for his dad he's got his wife dying
his son goes out shoots himself in his
head kills himself he didn't he had this
offhand remark that either I think about
and now he's got two people to bury and
that's and that's the end of Howard's
life it's not the end of his career in
some ways though because you know Weird
Tales publishes all these other stories
that he's got out there pending and he's
got quite a few sketches written that
other people will pick up later on and
so you notice most of the timelines that
I give you it ends with the author's
death with Howard I thought I would add
a few other things so about 10 years
after he dies this is August Derleth who
he'd started correspondence with and it
was you know the guy publishing
Lovecraft and and they were all kind of
one big big circle
he publishes through his Arkham House
here in Wisconsin his Arkham house
imprints a selection of Howard's best
stories as he thought they were called
skull face and others and this gets
people really interested in Howard again
and then eventually you're going to have
a couple different editions of Howard's
stories come out gnome press which was
publishing a lot of other sci-fi and
fantasy stuff at the time in 1950 they
runs from 1950 to 1956 they start to
publish more Conan stories but now
they're being edited and they're not
being edited by somebody I think
probably some some of us have done a
natori that work and so you know what
it's like to have a light hand in
editing you don't inject a lot of your
own stuff you know change things around
you just check the punctuation you know
make sure that that things flow all
right well L Sprague de Kamp was not
that kind of editor and so apparently
and I haven't length looked at the cross
there they're thinking sites where you
can go and see the things side by side
he really didn't change a lot he and he
was a great writer so it's not making it
bad but
it's it's taking it away from ya it's I
mean this is kind of an interesting
question to think about Before we jump
into like the the philosophical themes
it's another philosophical theme if you
have a writer how much can you change
their work before it ceases to be them
and one of the things I have in mind
my uncle Hubert used to have off this
whole shelf of Reader's Digest what were
they called they're these these like
classic books and yes condensed right
and so how do you condense a book well
you take out some of the sentences and
some of the passages and you just you
know you leave what just the gist of it
right so people could like you know read
Tom Sawyer and that maybe not be so
troubled with you know some of the long
discussions about stuff and just have
the high points you know sort of like
with a movie like they're watching next
door maybe you leave a lot of things on
the cutting floor so it goes from being
a two-and-a-half-hour movie down to an
hour-long movie right so with an author
like Howard here's there's a question
I'm proposing to you how much can you
cut or change before it ceases to be him
I mean there's still keep the name on it
all right so there's still Robert Howard
stories in a way the first attempt at
filming tokens trilogy all the Lord of
the Rings threw everything into a
two-hour about half of a I've never seen
them it was animated okay oh yes I did
see this yeah yeah yeah II haven't had a
musical number where the orcs are like
they're whipping people where there's a
whip there's a way yeah yeah it was
terrible
how much how much though they have to
take out whether or not these yeah Trudi
Tolkien versus well it was written with
the Peter Jackson stuff King I remember
being in a bookstore and like somebody
where there was really really angry and
they're angry about like some of the
scenes that that had been left out
essentially right or or where characters
have been a little bit condensed into
each other and the guy who was running
the bookstore was a very literate guy he
was like well what the hell did you
think he was going to do make it like 60
hours long you know well he won't do
that when they turn them into movies
because every single even even Orson
Scott Card's understand inner scale
anything everything like that has got to
be ended you have to figure out how to
make it fit yeah and that's a pretty
short book really Frank Herbert's dune
the first version for soon when they
tried to film it when was would suffer
are you taking out the one from the
1980s yeah it's kind of funny I mean if
you were trying to think of what
director to give something to have a
sort of like faithful interpretation of
a novel I sure as hell wouldn't get it
the David lunch
maybe that's the example is someone who
was true to the story true the author's
intent versus someone like David Lynch
yeah I mean he's very historian artist
but yeah well you don't let I mean
though before we sort of finish up the
biographical stuff for the the timelines
let's also talk about the cone a movie
or movies I think all of us have seen
them right and you've never seen the
original everything
well then they also had one recently to
a remake of it and that was awful you
know compared to the original one but
but the original one is pretty you know
it's deviating pretty far from the
source material it's not it's not
there's no like story that it's based on
I mean they're they're making Conan into
somewhat different guy that he that he
is in the stories so I mean does he
cease being coming in at some point or
should we say it's loosely based on well
both of the that's a good question one
of the things I wanted to talk about as
a philosophical themes is Conan's
intelligence because in the in the movie
okay he's not very articulate but you
could say well that's because you got
this guy who's like fresh off the boat
it doesn't speak much English
who's speaking for him but he doesn't
get a lot of great lines either in the
books he's pretty early in the stories
whether it's the original Howard stories
or the camp or Lynda Carter edited once
he's pretty intelligent and so the movie
can give you an impression that he's not
he's not as bright as he is that he's
sort of luck just lucky or doesn't think
things through well it strikes me
looking at his history yeah going into
stories yeah the weakling who's become a
strong man yeah and that strong man goes
into the stories yeah there's there's I
mean there's a lot of theories about
like why Howard writes the stuff that he
does and some of them talked about it
was like be wish fulfillment
and that one of the reason why those
stories were so successful was because
you have all these pulp readers who are
using conan order or call or or solvent
as it basically has like i mean the
action that was when we were young I
don't know about like in the 20s and 30s
I don't even if I don't know even though
Charles Atlas had his course up but in
the 40s certainly yeah it was certainly
out there in the 40s pretty heavily 40s
and 50s was real heavy
there are only a few variations is
almost always at a beach it just struck
me as I'm looking at us looking at his
history yeah that that may cut that may
have colored his his direction and then
the people who are buying it the people
who are reading it the audience you know
that makes you honest with sense we'd
probably be people who like you said
that wish fulfillment
yeah look at this think about being
somebody strong like Conan well not just
strong but also like successful he's got
all the best lines you know the hero
yeah and and one of the things that I
noticed you know you can notice that by
reading the stories but I also noticed
some of the commentators talking about
this howard is very smart he never tells
you how tall conan is just tells you
that he's massive he never he never
tells you exactly how strong he is
he's just stronger than everybody else
you know and he really depends you know
sort of depicts it rather than
describing to guarantee the audience's
mail
oh yeah interestingly another thing so
Howard I mentioned is various very smart
in how he would construct stories to
make to maximize his his income from the
pulps because that was his source of
income so if you if you put a woman into
the story then they would put a
woman on the cover and if they put a
woman on the cover it would sell better
so he was like I gotta have you know
exactly and so he would do that in some
of his stories and there's you know
there's accusations about him being not
just sexist but also a racist that's
something we should probably discuss
yeah when you look at him in his time I
don't want to say well oh it was okay or
something like that because of its time
but if you look at him in his time he's
actually kind of on the less racist
spectrum than most of his contemporaries
like HP Lovecraft he and Lovecraft
actually that's interesting dialogue
both about that and about fascism
Howard was definitely against fascism
actually you know while we're at that
digression I called a few lines out from
some of his letters that he had to
Lovecraft he said I know it's the
Phantom sneer at democracy but
democracy's not to blame for the
troubles of the world the men were most
to blame or the men who would now save
the country under the new name of Nazis
or fascists and then he says and another
one you accused me of heating human
development because I mistrust fascism
because there are a lot of people who
are saying fascism is like the way
forward at that time and he says well
there can't be much tolerance about a
system as advocates denounced as enemies
of humanity anyone who disagrees with
that according to that you considers any
enemies of humanity every man and woman
in the world there's not a fascist so
clearly he's he's you know dissociated
from that be say well okay maybe he's
just a libertarian racist that you know
the racism gets gets you know stripped
away from from that and well he's a
product at this time yeah and you can't
use our standards nobody that was raised
at the time he'd raised yeah I mean
another taxes yeah I mean another person
pointed out
is that you know he depicted there was
talking about you know he's got all
these sort of clashes of races in his
stories but they're not really clashes
of races so much as clashes of culture
because just about well a lot of people
are sort of reducible to their ethnicity
in these stories there's also like tons
of tons of characters who are out of
character for their ethnicity you know
anybody can be a mercenary anybody can
wind up in the pirates anybody can wind
up doing anything it's just that most
people don't most people wind up sort of
sticking with whatever they they grow up
with including the sumerians that Conan
you know stems from most of them are you
know just pretty brute creatures you
know bound by tempo sort of like when
we're talking about Fritz Leiber the
father character he wants to get the
hell out of that barbaric country
another person pointed out to that Conan
as a character he's a barbarian he
almost always ends up defending
civilization against either the the
ultra civilized you know like the people
from Santa you know those sorts of
things or from other barbarians who
fights against the Ash guardians he
fights against the pigs he fights
against all these these people and of
course fights against Apes things like
that oh well that's that's another
question I wanted to to explore so what
do you think about that I mean I'm only
halfway through and so far he seems to
be acting solely in self-interest but I
can see how it could be so up towards me
yeah so the question we have to ask is
well what makes what makes a character
heroic and whether whether some not all
self-interest because clearly like if
he's just in it for the money or
something like that that's not going to
work right or if he's just doing it to
impress some some woman that's not going
to work but there's some forms of
self-interest or we could say well that
might be heroic right maybe think about
the Odyssey and and how Odysseus
presents himself he's clearly
because he could from his perspective
its self-interest but from the
perspective of the people he's saving
saving yeah it's heroic so this is
indeed one and one of the one of the
themes that is glad you touched on this
is one of the themes that I wanted to to
talk about he he does display genuine
nobility from time to time when he
chooses to write and it's it's
interesting because it's kind of like an
equal-opportunity thing it's not because
of his his noble blood he doesn't have
any and it's not because of his culture
because he comes from a bunch of people
who have no culture that's all right but
he can be the person to rise to the
occasion and then sometimes like saved
the whole world now does that make him a
hero or not or do we need something else
for for heroism something else to think
about - oh that somebody pointed out in
an essay is almost all of his bad stuff
that would be kind of low class is a
sauce cream or or you know what's the
equivalent for books and off-screen it
happens you know offstage so he said
when we see Conan on stage we see him do
many things he intervenes in politics
and dynastic struggles of various
kingdoms so that sounds kind of heroic
right intervening and that he hunts for
hidden treasure
how can not really heroic more
self-interested he explores desert
islands of lost cities he fights
countless terrible monsters and evil
sorcerers that's pretty heroic right
he's saving people from those things he
saves countless beautiful women makes
them fall in love with him probably more
wish-fulfillment heroism than anything
they're what we virtually never see
Conan do is engage in the proper
business of an armed robber on land or
by sea which is to attack people who
never threatened or provoked you take
away their possessions by force and run
your sword through them dare to resist
so the way that Howard portrays oh well
he says he's a pirate over and over
again as a matter of fact there's four
different pirate fleets that he's he's
associated with he tells people that
he's a thief he's a robber he's all the
things and yet he doesn't the stories he
doesn't do any of that stuff so he
doesn't okay here's here's one possible
and I'm not endorsing this as an
interpretation but one possible
interpretation is Conan never really
does anything bad he just tells other
people that he does so they'll maybe
leave him alone and not not bring him in
to do even more altruistic heroic I
don't think that's the case but wouldn't
that be where that'd be a funny thing so
he's a complex figure when it comes to
the heroism don't people sometimes
create a persona that causes other
people to react to that a certain way so
someone who's not at all confident can
create a persona one who is very calm
yeah then people really they're in like
the c-suite and they're wondering how
the hell they got there because the
people are reacting to the persona that
they've created yeah to who they are and
what komen is doing is creating that
persona well so that's a good question
does he in these stories do anything to
actively create a persona by his words
or actions or is he simply being
revealed as the kind of guy that is
really frankly just doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know he he's gonna do what he wants
to do and as people get in his way then
they'll get hurt but you know most
people won't get in his way
collagen is interpretation again the
only thing how much it is the
interpretation of the beholder
he's this big brute guy yeah he must be
what if it's the pursue all the same
goal but it's the two sides of the same
coin I guess okay so like yeah there's
like Jays and pirate food yeah off
screen taste the shadows just
buddy basically but like on-screen he's
the moral he's the moral hero so he's
got the [ __ ] you on the self-interest in
person yeah so he's he's the vehicle in
motion but on screen he's the vehicle in
motion but it's pretty pretty colors
with morality of it well you know if you
look if you look at him and the other
people that are rivals maybe right there
they're they're not just like backdrop
people like the innkeeper that there are
other really finders or things like that
they're usually either like total bad
guys like they're you know they're
trying to bring the city down or they're
a sorcerer or something like that or
they're ineffective good guys and
they're ineffective like they might they
might be ineffective because even though
they're a great fighter they're bound by
notions of Honor that get them in their
men killed
where does Conan's not encumbered by
that now the question is are those
characters largely exist primarily just
to put conan apps or like they're the
setting for the jewel you know or i mean
i think some of them really are
characters in their their own right I
mean Howard could do what what george RR
martin does which is to take a character
that he's going to kill a few pages and
develop you know start to start
developing them in a way that where we
could actually start reviewing them
sympathetically and then you know they
get their throat cutter some eight
crushes their skull or something along
those lines every author has characters
that are the setting for the duel yeah
how how far they're developed and how
long they last question yeah the main
characters die
oh yeah well there's only one main
character Conan that story Masseria yeah
yeah and Martin was working towards
clearly only two or three main
characters do you think yeah
you mean I think he left Daenerys yeah I
think he was consciously working toward
Oh two or three main characters okay
well he even when couldn't we say he
actually has a whole field of main
characters and that he widows that bit
by bit hungry
he's doing like he was a gardener or oh
he was a gardener definitely author he
handed he would probably have in mind
who was gonna survive this yeah I mean
somebody sort of bringing this back a
little bit towards coming at somebody
who in the george RR martin stories I'd
gotten sort of sympathetically bound up
with and then I was kind of bothered by
the fact that he died and they they took
the easy road with the the show and it
brought him back to life was the Hound
you know and he spent page after page
after page developing this you know
rough misunderstood but ultimately in
some respects at least some respects
noble guy only to have them get get
killed you know any actor Mark Martin
loves doing that sort of thing in the
stories you know I mean Howard does it
doesn't have the luxury of doing that
because I mean you get yeah I mean the
longest thing that he wrote which which
is book length was still kind of a
stitch job
of episodes but yeah this is everything
is a really great question is is he
really a hero what does it take to be a
hero I mean is it that you you defend
other people you know Conan does now a
lot of the time he's not doing it for
the right reasons but you know another
thing now that we've sort of moved into
the philosophical themes part there are
proposals to read Conan as an
existentialist hero and I thought that
would be something interesting to talk
about so so what is an existentialist
hero it's somebody who sort of writes
their own script because there is no
predetermined fated you know some of the
rules out there we all have to kind of
make our own rules and the ones that
that are there in place for us that we
encounter are best suggestions that only
have value if we take them up now you
know if you go too far along that path
it starts to seem like well you can do
anything you want all right and then
you're you're you're a hero but you're
not really you might you know you might
do whatever you want and wind up
becoming very ignoble very very base but
there's a notion of him being
existentialist here I think is kind of
an interesting one there's that and
again to go back to the movie at the
very beginning of the movie Conan is you
know a slave and
he's got this this guy he's being
brought up with these warriors and one
of the warrior leaders asked some Conan
what is best in life because the other
guys get the answer wrong and he's got
this line that apparently comes from
Genghis Khan about you know seeing
you're going to be driven before you and
destroyed and hearing the lamentations
of their women which is not in the books
at all you know but that's an answer to
the question well what's what's best in
life the cony out of the books
why is he ranging through all these
different countries and doing all these
different things he's a restless guy
who's trying to figure out what is life
about you know is it about getting drunk
and getting laid and punching people's
faces in is it about you know daring
great deeds and killing monsters and you
know achieving renown is it about making
money is it about putting together you
know coalition or pirate fleet or
something like that these are these are
things that Conan gets to kind of play
around with so in a way he could be an
existentialist hero the other the other
person that people bring up of course
terms existentialism is Friedrich
Nietzsche
because Conan is sort of like a good
instance of what Nietzsche called the
over man or the uber match the Superman
he doesn't care what other people think
he imposes the order that he wants to
impose there's no attempt even when he
is king of Aquilonia to try to sort like
make everything work out rationally or
or you know have one big system that
everybody fits into I don't know if that
works I mean if the movie began with a
quote from Nietzsche actually that you
know what doesn't kill us makes us
stronger quote but in a way he's there's
an older idea that might fit Conan that
comes from Aristotle of the what
Aristotle called the greats old person
or we translate that as magnanimous
it's just you know from the latin magnet
anima greats great soul and this is a
person who does great things and knows
that they are worthy of many honors and
expect those honors but when it comes to
people lower than them in the hierarchy
they actually treat them well it's only
with people who are like not quite on
their level but close to their level who
might be rivals that they you know
behaved in a arrogant or haughty manner
now in area in Aristotle's view you
could only really have this in a
community so you could you could be this
magnanimous person in Athens because
you're an Athenian or and Greece as a
whole because your your agree the Coenen
is a guy without a country he's you know
he doesn't as far as I know go back to
Canaria or care about those people back
back home he's behaving that way in the
midst of other people so I don't know
that that might be a better
philosophical depiction of the kind of
guy that Conan is depicted as being than
the Nietzschean Superman he's a vision
of water oh he's not a fish out of water
he's if we want to use the fish metaphor
he's and we want to attack like in
Wisconsin terms
he's a muskie and a lake that's filled
with bluegill and bass you know and
every once in a while one of the bass
will will try to challenge it but the
bass isn't a muskie and there's other
stuff in the water too that you know
maybe
there's monster turtles or something
like that this muskie kills them know
the analogy starts to break down but no
he's not he's not a fish out of water
and this is another good good season
think about so one of the key dynamics
that that Howard is working with and
again something he wrote back and forth
to Lovecraft quite a bit is this
struggle between civilization and
barbarism and Lovecraft was sort of a
you know proponent of civilization
against barbarism
Howard was actually an admirer of
barbarism against civilization but
there's a third term there below
barbarism you have savagery so he's not
saying the you know be like totally
without any sort of social structure or
you know be like those you know
primitive caveman or something like that
the barbarian belongs to a middle state
between savagery where everything is at
the level of just like the individual
family or clan or something like that
and civilization where the whole culture
in place and laws organism people are
farming and building temples the
barbarians can't even in the this this
middle position and Howard viewed
barbarism and barbarian societies as a
place where you know Humanity was
actually developing and you had the
optimal opportunity for a sort of
expression of the individual and and
freedom and in a way he's kind of like
one of the philosophers who talks about
this in Jean Jacques Rousseau Rousseau
had a similar thing where you've got
savagery and he actually thought that
you know in the state of nature or you
know the noble savage Humanity was
happiest then but civilization was
definitely crap for Rousseau you know
everybody like has to repress their
instincts and replace them with new
kinds of feeling and we get all these
distinctions of like rain
and money and power and you know pretty
soon you get to lead something they you
know changes the very language so it
suits them
and it becomes corrupt right and in
between you have barbarism and the bar
the barbarian people are you know they
have got they have laws and they have
mores but if they sort of inflict them
on themselves and they're much more
dynamic than the one of the words that
were so loved to use was enervated you
guys know that that term so civilized
people were enervated which means that
they've kind of lost their energy you
know think about thinking about the
people that that are you know like
constantly just sitting in their chairs
and typing away on their computers and
they don't do anything and they they
have to go outside to get vitamin D from
the Sun so that's you know that and
that's the the civilized person so
Howard thought that something kind of
like Rousseau you know that that
barbarism was was in some respects
better and you know he saw civilization
as always being threatened by barbarians
so you know on that map that I gave you
you you've got all these these civilized
kingdoms you know the Hyborian right
this is from the Hyborian age so aqwal
onea and the media and hyperborea
they're being threatened by the pics or
the pic dish wilderness totally savage
people they're below the level of
barbarism and then you've got these
barbaric people the Sumerians who are
descended from the old Atlanteans the
vanaheim and ice guard who are sir like
Vikings basically you know Howard by the
way when he's doing his world-building
he had no problem like lifting entire
peoples out of history changing the
names very slightly and then plugging
them down
well did they have the theory of
economic flames by this time because I
was that's a good you watch my book they
have like yeah they have they have this
man yeah they have like a copy of the
world basically next to it in my area
yeah so so they I don't know if that
theory was in play but they knew that
mountains would would arise and cuz he
actually in he's got this assay the
Hyborian age where he talks about like
the landscape and the peoples within it
and these these things like the mountain
ranges that you see on there is like
piling up and separating peoples off
from each other but I don't know I don't
know enough about about earth science to
tell you whether that was a major theory
at the time I suspect probably I mean by
the 20s maybe I don't but I don't know
but in any case you see these you know
there's people that are being they're
coming down from the north and they're
there there's a border kingdom there to
try to keep them off of them you know
the marches and then you've got these
like super civilized places in the south
and then further down it goes back to
barbarism and savagery and you know the
barbarians are always ready to come in
and threaten civilization and take over
now it's kind of interesting because
historically that's not quite how things
played out like if you think about the
Roman Empire and the way that we teach
it in history books which was mostly be
us right we say oh you know these German
tribes and they're so uncivilized and
you know the Romans have conquered these
other barbarians like the you know the
Gauls and who you know actually like
sack Rome at one time and these other
people over here and they they're
conquering the Britons not quite
successfully so they built Hadrian's
Wall and then things just kind of stayed
the way they were for a while then these
Germans came in raised holy hell and
knocked everything down then we have the
Dark Ages
yeah that's total BS because what would
happen it was for hundreds of years
Germans have been sir
the Roman army because Roman citizens
are like I'm not serving in the army
this is this is a crap job let's let
somebody else do it so there is an
entire class of people called the
Federer do the Allies who are
essentially romanized Germans Goths you
know all sorts of other Germans and they
would they would serve and they would
become essentially Romans and view
themselves as Romans even though they
were a German blood and this went on
over and over again and then when when
the tribes finally came through and
started knocking things down they
haven't actually like you know tear
building was down or stuff like that
they wanted them to stay in place
because they wanted to be Romans they
wanted to stay on the scene and enjoy
all the fruits of that so you know by
the by the you know late for hundreds
when when you've got these barbarian
kingdoms established there's still a
Roman Senate and they're still meeting
and they're still advising the current
Roman Emperor in the West who happens to
be say King Otis er you know or King
so-and-so and all of this is going on
and all the power structure is sort of
staying in place and the fabric of Roman
law it's not until a bit later that that
things start to really fall apart and
some of that had to do with
environmental things you know the earth
started going through a cooling period
harvest got got worse
the Vikings coming down and raiding
stuff that really tore stuff up because
the Vikings weren't there to like for
the most part at first at least to sort
of you know establish their dominance
within an already civilized area but
then they got into that too so we get
you know like the Normans those are
Vikings you know Sicilians the the
Vikings sailed all the way down there
and then when these barbarians would
come in and take over they'd be like hey
you know it's nice having fields that
people will actually farm and social
structures oh this stuff let's just
establish ourselves as the new elite and
this goes all the way
back to Mesopotamia I mean within the
Fertile Crescent you had these these you
know people who'd come in from the
outside and then take over and they
would establish themselves as the the
new ruling class and then things would
go back to business as usual so there's
this constant dynamic between
civilization and barbarism and Konan is
sort of the preeminent representative of
barbarism and what it could provide but
most barbarism kind of sucks because it
means like not having very good
technology and being stuck you know
believing in superstitions and listening
to you know your local priest telling
you you know got to do this Coenen at
least is fortunate and then he's got a
God who doesn't care about him at all
you know there were a few passages that
I wrote down about crime it's a
brilliant brilliant idea here yeah here
we go these are from two of the stories
conan says Crom dwells on a great
mountain what used to call on it little
he cares if men live or die better be
silent than to call his attention to you
he'll send you dooms not fortune he is
grim and loveless but at birth here's
the key idea he breathes power to strive
in a sleigh into a man's soul what else
shall man they ask of the Gods so it's
sort of like you got your you got your
whatever you're gonna get from the gods
upfront now don't bother them with your
your prayers or whining or anything like
that because you've got everything that
you need and he says in another one the
Tower of the elephant it was useless to
call on crime because he was a gloomy
Savage God and he hated weaklings but he
gave him an courage at birth and the
will and might to kill his enemies which
in the sumerians mind was all any God
should be expected to do so you know for
Conan that's about as much religion as
there is there's tons of religions in
the stories right people are worshipping
in a mitra or Orsat or whoever you like
but Conan doesn't doesn't worry about
any of that sort of stuff he got his you
know score settled with God at the
beginning and you know he's so he's not
a typical barbarian in many respects but
there is this this this sort of back and
forth you know civilizations striving
with each other and you know Howard is
using race in this but I think he's
talking more about culture as well the
other theme that I really wanted to hit
on was and it's ties it with the world
building itself
you know it's an amoral universe for for
Howard we mentioned this thing at the
very beginning about him living through
an oil boom and getting to see as a
teenager sort of the worst sides of
human nature during this oil boom in his
hometown
how people would exploit each other how
easy fight fights could start so in this
world that that Conan inhabits there is
no real cosmic law of justice there's
all sorts of religions but the gods
don't help you out very much you know
Crom doesn't care at all but crime is
kind of a minor God even the big gods
who are being worshipped they don't
actually fix things and then there's all
sorts of other evil gods
well actively try to make things bad for
you
demons things that can be brought from
other planes and human beings in the
stories one of the things I do like
about these stories is that the human
beings in them it really is a
cross-section of humanity they have all
sorts of different motives you know some
people are motivated by greed some
people are motivated by noble
aspirations but unable to see them
through others are just trying to stay
alive and dynastic conflicts some are
motivated by lust some are you know just
thinking about their next next meal or
something along those lines and these
these different motives can be
coordinated they can be manipulated
oftentimes they're at cross-purposes but
there's no there's no one single value
that
it's everything in this so you can kind
of make your own path if you choose to
it's a it's a universe that's full of
violence sort of like the the Texas that
Howard grew up in theory in psychology
yeah your world you get set about the
age of ten to twelve by interesting what
you're experiencing yeah so you
experience violence and getting beaten
up and bullied yeah so the theory is
that what you experience around that
time in your life since your view of the
world yeah you know and he's also got a
he's also good family conflict his mom
felt that she had married beneath her
she was pretty bookish kind of a you
know philanthropic kind of person his
father was more hard-nosed
it was a local doctor you know and he
was much closer to his mom than he was
to his dad so I mean that could play a
role too yeah I mean one of the things
that really ties in with that if you
think about the oil boom right it's a
it's a it's a activity that's got some
structure because there's a name get oil
out of the ground and there's money
being thrown at it but everything else
is kind of up for grabs
it's whatever somebody can can impose so
you sup you know to use an example from
this time a hamburger stand and these
guys who are you know the oil miners you
charge them whatever the hell you can
because you need to make money off of
them while they've got money coming in
that's up to you
I mean you could have some guy who's
like I'm only going to charge a fair
price well that's his choice and he's
gonna you know not prosper the guy who
you know squeezes everything out of them
for the hamburgers he's probably gonna
make a lot of money he may go bust the
next week but a lot of the activities
that are happening in these stories are
kind of like that you know there are
mercenary armies or pirate fleets right
or this or that where you've got a whole
bunch of people coming in and there's
some common purpose but it's something
that people involved how they sort that
out and so somebody who's strong will
you know steer things to fit their
either their advantage or the way that
they think think think things ought to
happen well and the other people will
kind of have to go along with it you
know I think that kind of fits
Howard's views on things now that said
you know sometimes justice does get done
in this news stories but it's
unpredictable you know like the bad guys
sometimes do get killed by Conan or
sometimes they like they even you know
screw the screw things up and like you
know poison themselves or things along
those lines but you can't count on it
happening you know it's not like a
morality tale where the guy with the
white hat is gonna shoot the guy with
the black hat and save you know the
town's folk from this and that it might
happen it might not you know that's an
interesting question so it's hard to say
there are five or six different
timelines out there from people who some
of the building themselves is like
Howard or Conan scholars and they
arrange the stories like well this story
must have happened first and this story
was to happen later and they don't all
agree I mean it's clear that like you
know like which ones were published
first you can you can do that but it's
trying to reconstruct there's no
well there's it's sort of like with like
Plato's dialogues right scholars agree
like this dialogue must have been really
early in this diet like we know the laws
was Plato's last words we're super long
very complicated high level of thought
and it's not well written so we're
pretty confident that one was last but
which one actually was the first one
we're not really sure but we can be you
know we can be fairly confident that
like some of the dialogues are much
later than others and and we can say
similar things there's ways to make
sense of the storyline but but there's
little shifts here and there and so what
you'd have to do is like decide which
line you want and then look at the
stories and then say does how do you
tell if a character develops they change
their mind on some things right and they
they express it or they they act
differently given a the same kind of
situation so we'd have to do that and I
don't have an answer I don't I don't
know it's kind of a mishmash for me I
just kind of read around and I'm like
what like we're in a labyrinth or a
cathedral or like that but Howard Howard
himself was changing over time you know
oh you know and as he got older he
apparently became less racist which is
kind of you know an interesting
development especially given that it was
the 30s and I think a lot a lot of
people were swinging the other way he
maybe became less sort of traditionally
sexist he had a few female characters
who had some genuine like agency we
don't know what he would have done if
he'd lived longer and that might have
been due to the influence now his mom
but but if his girlfriend
novalee he also went through phases were
you know like he was writing this sort
of stuff like I'm at
when he died he hadn't been really
writing much fantasy he thought he might
turn back to doing fantasy but he's
really doing a lot of Westeros because
he'd become fascinated with that when he
died I'll mention to the he animal he
left the library behind and his library
included a lot of interesting stuff here
we go
his father presented his library to that
college that he'd attended Howard Payne
College there was a lot of history and a
lot of fiction
there was also biographies sports poetry
he also liked to write poetry
anthropology which makes a lot of sense
texana I didn't even know there wasn't
John recalled texana and erotica so so
he had pretty wide tastes you know and
he was probably adding to it he also you
know was was involved in all this
correspondence too with other other
writers and maybe that was broadening
horizons some of it was with HP
Lovecraft and I think his arguments with
Lovecraft words were quite productive
for him having to articulate to somebody
else who's you know really heavy hitter
and real pure his ideas like why fascism
is a bad idea
Lovecraft flirted with fascism you know
or why barbarism is better than
civilization when you've got resistance
like that yeah so yeah the only other
theme that I had that I wanted to bring
up was that one that we talked about a
little bit earlier that he's really a
smart barbarian and I was reading an
essay earlier today that was talking
about how people who were unfamiliar
with Conan think of him he was talking
about how he's an iconic figure like
Tarzan or or spider-man or things like
that and those who haven't read the
stories think of Conan as
dumb guy if you read the stories it's
clear that he's actually very smart and
so he said they're believing in an
unconscious public perception that is
straining the character down to its
simplest and accurate depiction and he
put it out that cohan's not a
philosopher he's not he's not a guy
making long complex arguments but he was
more than capable of elucidating his
thoughts on what he wanted from life so
he's able to articulate what his
worldview is and what he wants he lives
through his body but he whenever it
needs to use his mind he does use his
mind and this is the other thing that I
brought up before this is also from that
essay Howard's most famous heroes Conan
and call don't remain warriors in
anonymous barbarian hordes they do
mercenaries service and civilized lands
they don't become kings of barbaric
people's they get put on the throne of
civilized lands and then once they do
that they strengthen their countries
against the barbarians there's aliens
from from this essay by Don here and the
dark barbarian which is kind of an
interesting idea that goes back to the
heroism thing to once Conan is actually
in charge of anything he sort of works
for the common good you know rather than
taking bribes or you know diverting
troops off to kill his enemies or
anything like that so he's kind of a
good guy in spite of himself which again
might be some character wish fulfillment
on Howard's part or I don't know but III
know I I really enjoy going back and
rereading you freeze stories I they were
there wasn't any moment where I was
where you know some of the thinkers who
we've talked about whereas like wow this
guy really builds a lot of philosophical
depth into his
like say philip k dick does you know or
Ursula K the green but they're great
stories you know they're fun to read
they they stand up
it's almost sent quite a hundred years
later but yeah so yeah well be coming up
too so if the first one is Phoenix on
the sort of 1932 another another decade
and then a few years will be coming up
to the centenary of that hopefully we'll
all see it you know what else do you
guys want to and they're intelligent how
much of that is colored by their
experience of the movie yeah people like
I know many people who don't read
fantasy yeah
sci-fi who don't read speculative
fiction do you think they've seen the
movie though well but they've seen
advertising or they've seen these movies
out there yeah and they form an
impression of what the literature is
about without having actually read it
yeah I wonder too if there are you know
like other barbarians kind of floating
around is the swords and sorcery genre
that are much dumber that they also got
the idea from how much well they didn't
make exactly a Brainiac in the first
movie no won't ever that second I was
thinking about that earlier today like
fighters and magic he is amazing
Roy Greenhill from the border of the
stick which is actually a webcomic
okay the twist there is Roy as the party
well you know we do this with like a lot
of people to dump John it's can't be
strong
that's Marta the same smart the same
physical and mental powers you know you
gotta survive I think it's a human
tendency to choose to put somebody in a
category yeah that's how we operate well
to be fair I think a lot of people also
do that with themselves where they're
like well I'm you know I'm strong so I
don't need to be smart you know or I'm
good you know people do that with good
looking I'm good looking I don't need to
like have tails it's pretty thing like
that or like when I was a kid my mom did
something really awful with me and my
sister which is you know she divided us
into like I was the intelligent one and
my sister was the artistic one and
that's a terrible thing to tell them you
know that first of all that intelligence
and creativity are some Hollings effort
for each other
but you know as it turned out she wasn't
very artistic so she was being steered
away from developing your mind and I
think she kind of bought it for a long
time and tried to do something that she
wasn't really well-suited for and you
know quite hard on her language skills
and math oh yeah possible just for high
in both especially being a girl so you
have these pigeon holes either this or
this yeah so so the Barbarian I guess
to casualty of that I had speaking from
personal experience and trying to break
into two different categories for them
so yeah well strength and mental
I guess probably yeah you know if you
are I mean if you are smart I think it's
probably good to to be strong at the
same time you know yeah
I mean I think for a while before we
knew as much about like longevity in the
body it could make sense to like you
know be the smart guy who is in front of
the computer screen all the time or
something like that
but now I mean it like I I'm trying to
realize this if I want to continue doing
the sort of things that I do which are
primarily intellectual I have to go and
work out I'm putting that way because
I'm going to go to the wack in a bit and
exercise because I don't want my bones
to you know start getting brittle and I
want my I don't want my heart to be to
be impeding me and then you know I'm not
getting enough oxygen or whatever he's
gonna go on I mean these are not a
scientific exact things but but you know
we know a lot more about the connection
now between the body and the mind that
you can't afford to just neglect your
body but but I think a lot of people do
it's really easy to do what are you're
young because you can get away with them
this isn't is cheap
yeah true one and we do sort of reward
people for over specializing to to no
way yes especially our society yeah I'd
say that I can remember specific times
in my life where I was punished for
being there's an old expression jack of
all trades master of none
yeah
shallow versus yes is that that's
another categorization that happens yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah I never I never liked that
that ideology you know I thought that
was great for like people who like
wanted to be one of those things and
then not have an excuse for why they
couldn't hear the other one bring
simplifies things the brain likes likes
to simplify it and put it into one
category and it's more difficult for the
brain to function brain doesn't function
in terms of those broader categories
without us working at it yeah choose to
think the natural reaction of the brain
is to simplify it put one headline yeah
you know I was reading pops called the
other day because I was talking about a
video and he has this great distinction
that's kind of sort of like the
left-brain right-brain thing but but
it's much more sophisticated between
what he calls the it's translated as the
geometric mind or the arithmetic mind
it's the esprit de gijón that literally
the the spirit of axiomatic minor you
call it and then the what's translated
it badly as the intuitive line because
it's played of finesse which means like
having a sense for how to do things and
he says okay so you got you know people
who can grasp formal systems very well
because there's only a few axioms they
have to work to get those axioms but
once they do it man they just go to town
you know so like deductive logic isn't
like that and that works for certain
like expert system things it's great and
then there's the people who can figure
out
how to you know deal with things that
have a lot of different variables like a
political scientist you know somebody
who's not just crunching numbers but
somebody who's actually like thinking
about okay how does this society work
and how do we unpack it that would be
more the what do you know this is free
to fee nose and then Pascal says you
know there's some people who don't have
either of these you know and those are
just adult people
now then he says and both of these need
each other you know if you want to be
really really good at your game you
can't just be you know geometry mind
person you need some of that fee ness
and then you can then you're really
unstoppable and same thing with these
pretty different assets you need some of
the other side and I think too often we
like you said we do these sort of binary
well you're either this we were this and
we give people excuses for not
developing both sets of capacities or
maybe five sets of capacities you know
yeah I see religion yeah it's easier to
say this is the easy answer I do this
yeah everything's fine
and it's the black or white yeah I see
people who are very comfortable with
them that person you know it's one or
the other instead of the gray you know
we have much more difficulty with the
gray yeah which is what you're talking
about with political sciences you see
the variations and the variables yeah
sometimes sometimes the gray is
genuinely gray and sometimes it's such a
complex picture gothic is that there is
black and white still in it I was
thinking this is actually a good place
to close because we'll run all the time
pretty soon when it comes to like
religious thinkers the ones who I've
always found most interesting to read
like like Paschal are the people for
whom once religion enters the scene it
doesn't make anything simpler it just
makes everything a hell of a lot more
complex oh there's like a bigger richer
picture to try to make sense of like the
people who who like you're talking about
who you know well I got I found Jesus
and now everything
falls into place well that's probably
not Jesus that you know because it
wasn't like that for Saint Augustine you
know presumably he found him he wouldn't
written any of these books afterwards if
it if it was you know the box wouldn't
be complicated you know and so so I
always find the people who whatever
religious perspective they're bringing
it just makes for a much more
complicated and sometimes not well
decided picture certainly knowing that
psychics often just got to do this
well great conversation next time we're
doing Clark the Clark that we didn't go
to last
[Applause]
you
[Music]